Thank You Adam so this talk is sort of
like how do we do anomaly detection for
real world systems this is sort of based
on my experience of different algorithms
I tried over the past year while working
on a project called defend at stealth
bits and so let's get into it so let's
talk about anomaly detection first thing
first what is an anomaly well that's
sort of a million-dollar question
because it's like so hard to define like
what makes something anomalous it's more
like you know when you see it it's like
oh that thing's different I don't know
why it's just different and you really
can't come up with like a good like
rigid formal definition of anomaly it's
just like something that's no sleep
different from other things and one
thing to keep in mind is that what may
even seem anomalous are different now
maybe seem normal like the future for
examples couple of months ago when
Pokemon Gophers came out you know it's a
huge increase in like foot traffic to
parks that might seem anomalous at first
but then it sort of became normal as
like Pokemon go and then like every day
more and more people came to these parks
because I hear like the rare Pokemon
there so you need keep things like that
in mind I'm like oh that's not anomalies
this is just like a new trend and see
nice or just be able to sting your
eating habits too and also another thing
like depending on the setting you do it
you also have to keep in mind that it
might not be in a data neutral setting
so if you're like me you work in
computer security
most of these attackers or sort of
trying not to get caught they serve
design their behavior so that they don't
trigger your systems this is come
different from like regular machine
learning where it's like you may be
trying to classify the iris flower it's
like those fire those flowers are not
trying to trick you it's like this
flower is not trying to pretend to be
this other flower and that's the huge
thing you care about what are you doing
anomaly detection it's like is your data
sorbets in a neutral setting or are you
caring about like their adversary who's
trying to trick you who's trying to get
past you so I'm sorry we talked about
different ways to do this so there are
two like I guess the general idea is how
we can do this one is so we can develop
a statistical model like what's normal
so we can say like okay normal behavior
follow some multivariate Gaussian
distribution and then we look at our
data and look at people's behavior and
say oh hey according to this model this
guy only has like a one in a million
chance of doing this but he did it
that's really rare
that's really suspicious let's flag him
or we can serve the other machine
learning approach and sort of like
implicitly build less like probability
models so we can use like decision trees
or we can use support vector machines
and which is we sort of take data and
then we classify users I sort of like
normal or anomalous and so this has this
big issue we use the normal machine
learning approach the anomalies should
be very rare in your data like there are
nominees because they don't occur often
so like you have this huge imbalance in
your data set and you start need to
address that when you do machine
learning models and so over the like
past let's say decade sort of started
developing a special algorithms
specifically designed to deal with the
NAM beliefs so uses special like
probability models that sort of taking
the fact that the B's rare events to
occur or machine learning models that do
take in fact that oh hey there's gonna
be this huge imbalance in our normal
examples on our anonymous examples so
from this point I'm talking about like
anomaly detection in three different
settings using a call various algorithms
there's gonna be something similar to
like the last talk except a bit less
mathematical and so the first problem
say we have a data stream so we have
data coming in real time and we want to
be able to figure out like anomalies as
soon as the data comes in so this is
sort of like the holy grail of anomaly
detection if you can like do this in
real time you can sell that software to
anyone it's like oh hey I can tell you
attack is happening as soon as happening
boom just use our software
I guess the holy grail of like computer
security and solitaire is simple like we
have the data coming in a stream we can
see the events happening but we need to
be able to react quickly so you can't do
anything too complicated because we have
to give it a decision in like a couple
of seconds so we can only look at like
maybe last 100 500 events and we can't
really do much computations we have to
do something quick we do something in
memory and then we can act on rapidly so
how we're going to do this well let's go
back to our statistics 101 class we
might have learned something called the
z-scores right you might have learned
you take the z-score and get a p-value
and if that p-value is less than 0.05
you do your happy dance because then you
can reject the null hypothesis but let's
talk about what z-score really means
it's sort of like this test statistic
that sort of measures
how extreme of observation is like if
the observation is extreme enough then
disease Scout leaves the z-score is very
high in absolute value and we reject our
null hypothesis so the z-score sort of
like this measure of extremists and it
has like two main parts it has the mean
and standard deviation and it started
looking measure of like how many
standard deviations away from the mean
you are you're like three standard
deviations there are five standard
deviations and if you are three standard
deviations five society VJs that's a
very extreme and we like rejecting so
we're going to use this idea of like a
mean and standard deviation we're going
to modify a bit cuz it turns out mean
and standard deviation aren't really
good at handling anomalies and so well
first things first like let's talk about
how we do this in like data streams so
first we have a moving average and a
moving standard deviation we look at the
last end points we keep track of the a
mean of the last end points I'm gonna
keep tracks with standard deviation in
last night employees and then we can
just calculate those z-scores on the fly
each of those points would say oh hey
here's some point take out the moving
mean divided by the moving standard
deviation boom we have a z-score for
that and with the flag if the z-score
sees some threshold it feels like above
three or fours above four we flag it but
I was saying like the mean standard II
should have some problems they're very
sensitive to extreme values and the
thing is both of these are very
sensitive like one extreme value have a
dataset of like a thousand points and
then like one value that's super high
compared to everything else it will
greatly skew the standard deviation and
all the greatness skews Amin and as a
result the belly of these z-scores
really decrease in effectiveness of
these Z scores it increases the fit like
a lot when you have extreme values so
how do we deal with that and so just
before I go on how we do that let's talk
about like why this mean and standard
deviation is so sensitive to these
extreme values well what is the mean
well it turns out you might have learned
means okay I take the eight points you
divide by the number there are boom
that's the number what actual
optimization is that doing well it turns
out that the mean is actually the number
that solves this optimization at top you
basically trying to do this optimization
if you've taken like functional analysis
course this is the optimization in the
l2 norm
essentially what happens is you have you
trying to pick some number s such that
when you take the s each of your
observations minus s square that sum
that up and take the set ve square root
of that you find the s that sort of
minimizes that so it's like basically
you have a vector of points you have
your vector S which is just like vector
field SSSs asked and trying to minimize
the distance between it - and this is a
big issue because that squared term so
if this is small like this is 1 this
isn't an issue but Li have like X I -
ass being ten thousand ten thousand
squared is big number like 1 times 10 to
10 okay so that's gonna like greatly
impact that some so that's a result
those extreme valleys are grinning
greatly those extreme deviations are
gonna greatly impact the sum in fact
some and thereby impact the mean we
don't want that well what can we do
about it well we can use the median and
turns out the median is actually this
optimization in the l1 space so
basically what you do when you take the
median is you're trying to optimize find
well that should be a em instead of an S
am i bad so basically what you're trying
to do is you have your list of numbers
and trying to find em especially
minimize the absolute distance so like
then take the absolute value of the
distance and you sum that up and finally
and that minimizes that and so when you
do this it turns out that the median is
actually more robust against those
extreme values you have that deviation
of 10,000 it already continues 10,000
10,000 to some is in contribute odd
would be the 10 billion to the sum and
so doesn't result like median and this
optimization in the l1 norm is more
robust to extreme values and this is an
idea we're gonna come back and talk
about later on in this slide but just
remember that l2 optimization is
sensitive to outliers l1 is robust and I
guess general thing for people who are
like interested in mathematics the
higher LP space as you go you're more
sense of your auric to extreme values if
you do like an l-3 optimization or an l5
or even al affinity you're
senses two-year outliers and just as so
visualize this so basically the idea is
I created a data set up like a hundred
points of just like value hundred and I
threw in one extreme value and so the
extremists of the values on the bottom
on the x-axis and then I show how the
mean and standard deviation are affected
by it and if you know so you sort of see
this like exponential shape it should be
more quadratic but as you see like just
by extremely increasing one value just
fixing the data set and only changing
one value it can greatly affect the mean
and greatly affects the standard
deviation so this is where we talked
about the median so let's talk about how
can we the medians serve like analogous
to our mean it's sort of like a measure
of central central sensuality so now
what's the analogous of the central
standard deviation well that's called
the median absolute deviation and it's
given by this formula essentially the
median absolute deviation it's sort of
like a way to think about the spread of
data standard deviations why do I think
about spread but it's sensitive to our
extremeness so let's talk about the
median absolute deviation it's basically
you take each number on each of your
observations subtract the median and
take the median of that and so the
standard deviation you might remember
sort of like the mean of the deviation
up from the means and so the median
absolute deviation is not like the
median from the deviation from the
median answer gives you this way this
I'm just measure of spread from of the
data that sort of doesn't care about
those extreme values and one way to
visualize this esterday we have the data
set the blue points represent our data
this red arrow pointing up represents
the mean the bottom of the green arrow
pointing down represents the median and
the left and right arrows represent the
measure of spread so for the red left
red arrow and the right right the right
red arrow we have two standard
deviations and so we have this one point
out here this one Blue Point extreme
value it's greatly throwing off the
standard deviation it's like most of
data is within two standard ei shoes
just because that Blue Point is way out
there on the other hand we have the
median and we have two median absolute
deviations above and below the median
and you can see
and then like it doesn't really care
about this like extreme value out here
it's much smaller it's much more robust
and captures more of the data and sort
of like better for this extreme value so
now we have this median and we have this
meeting absolute deviation let's go back
to that z-score idea we can now talk
about modified z-scores so instead of
using z-score which is like X minus mean
over standard deviations we can now do
calculate modified z-score you basically
do X minus the median over the modified
absolute deviation median absolute
deviation and then you throw in this
multiplied by this constant point six
seven four five that's just so like it
works out nice math mathematically when
you integrate things it's just like a
constant of just for the integration
basically this allows you to use this
modified z-score and so now we can like
how this better measure of extremists to
4i data that isn't thrown off by our
outliers because like as the outliers
come in they sort of increased them they
would increase the mean and standard
deviation and the future points would be
less suspicious or considered less
extreme whereas with the modified
z-scores because we're using median and
median absolute deviation which are
robust to the extremeness
they sort of like stayed constant
behavior as I looked through new points
and then we can sort of use these marfa
z scores the same way we need to use
these s normal z-scores so if we can say
like it's the modified z-score is above
three or four it's above three point
five then we flag it as being highly
suspicious now let's talk about density
based anomaly detection so this is
basically a point in space so now we
have so now we don't have to do this in
real time it's not like data streams
what we need to do like real time view
quick and dirty we're now starting to
help the post space we can now do them
like much more complicated calculations
in computations and so we have our
points and some n-dimensional space and
our goal is to find which point is so
like no Swede ifferent from the others
and so if you look at this plot you
couldn't kind of see you like which one
is no stoolie different this is guy way
up here that's like way far away from
all the other points there's a goal of
like density based anomaly textures is
we want to be able to figure out this
person we want to be able to flag him as
being different from everyone else and
so just a quick primer about like we
talked about density based methods in
like machine learning like DB scan
things like what do we mean by density
well we're talking about probability
density so in statistics you soon like
the data generated by some probability
density functions if you take a stats
course it's like the PDF of a
distribution a normal distribution has
that PDF of like 1 over 2 pi bla bla bla
bla
for example mm-hmm and so the goal
density based methods it's sort of like
trying to estimate the underlying
probability density function generating
the data and then based on using that we
can sort of use the estimated density
function to sort of classify things so
for like DB scan or level set tree
clustering we looked at the density
function and we can classify points to
get cluster points together based on
like do they come from the same areas of
density and so this algorithm talked
about it's called local isla or factor
it's a pretty famous like anomaly
detection algorithm sort of like the
standard one for this type of problem
and there's been many like improvements
to it over the past couple years but the
goal is to sort of like clown to 5 the
relative density about a point and so
the idea is that like if your anomaly
you should be like way oscillated by
yourself and so the relative density
about you should be very small you're
coming like a very sparse region by
yourself you're not like in the middle
of all the points with all your friends
around here like these have very high
density regions this is a low density
region because it's a very sparse and
the way we're going to do this is by
sort of looking at a small neighborhood
around each point and saying like ok
based on the size of this neighborhood
we can sort of quantify the relative
density of each point and so where we do
this is for each data point we're going
to calculate the K distance so this K
distance is the near distance to the K
nearest neighbor so if you've heard of
like knn algorithm K nearest neighbor
you basically calculate the distance you
like the K the nearest point and so this
essentially we're going to do and here
uh stick behind this is that like the K
distance is gonna give us some notion of
volume like think back to like your
elementary school science course you
learn density is equal to mass over
volume well what's our mass in this case
the mass is the number of points
contained in our circle the volume is
sort of like size of a circle and so the
goal is the idea behind this is that
like the farther away you are from
everyone else the higher like volume you
should have so compared to this point
like this outlier
this is this cade distance it's huge
because it hasn't look very far away to
find five points close to it on the
other hand this guy who's in the middle
of everyone does they have to look that
far to find five and other points he's
looking center of attention he can find
five friends really easily and now so we
have the K distance we can now talk
about the reachability distance so the
reachability distance is sort of like a
pseudo distance metric and it sort of
gives us a way to think about like how
do your neighbors think about you so the
reachability distance - sort of like the
match between the K distance of B and
the actual distance between a and B and
so the thing is just like if you were
one of your nearest if you so basically
idea is that like how your neighbors see
you so if this guy so the outlier his
neighbors don't really see them as like
one of his friends so like you maybe so
this red point here and this green point
here this is one of his nearest
neighbors but he's not one of his
nearest neighbors so it's like if you're
an outlier your closest friends don't
see you as a friend yeah I hit too close
to home for some of you guys right okay
yeah so essentially if you're a normal
point then your closest friends see use
one of their friends if you're an
outlier your closest friends don't see
you is one of their friends association
with that reach ability distance so over
like intuitive it captures and that's
how we're gonna use it for actually
calculating destiny so now we can
actually calculate like I said the goal
is to like compute the relative density
this is where we're gonna actually do
this now so with the local reachability
density we're gonna sort of compute the
average reachability distance distance
from each of his points of each of its
neighbors and so we're gonna use this
formula and essentially what happens is
that if your reach ability distance to
your neighbors is
low so you like you're an outlier then
the usability distance to your neighbors
should be the distance between you and
them like it shouldn't be the cadence so
this is gonna be like a very large
summation because you're gonna have to
like look very far to get to your five
nearest neighbors and so this
denominator becomes high thus the
overall thing because it's looking very
small value so if you're an outlier this
would be very small on the other hand if
you're a normal point the average reach
ability to your neighbors should be
about the same it should be you're about
your K distance therefore this is sort
of like a more constant term it should
be some larger value and then we can
completely the local outlier factors
where we take the average local reach
ability deaths of your neighbors and
divided by the average of your local
reach ability distance local reach
ability density and so what this will do
is sort of compare it's like the density
of your neighbors compared to density of
you and this is important if you're a
normal point the density of your
neighbors should be about the same as
yours like you're coming from the same
space you're in the same red
neighborhood so this should be about 1
if you're a normal point on the other
hand if you're this outlier the density
of your friends is much higher than the
density of yours
so like this value will be very big at
all so large value divided by small
value gives you large value on top so as
a local outlier factor score gets higher
the more like you are an outlier and so
what we can do and practice when you use
local ally factor as you certainly
calculate this local outlier factor
score for each point if value is 3 or 2
point 5 that is basically something
spooky because that like number
basically gives you about like how much
more dancer neighbors are compared to
you if you're a local outlier factor for
this guy is like two point three eighths
or two point nine so it's about three so
sayst about three and say okay here's
local outlier factor scores about three
that means his neighbors come from a
region that is three times as dense as
his neighborhood that's really
suspicious because that music comes from
a very different like probably probably
density region and like I said a normal
point should have about score between 1
and 1 point 5 they're about the same
density as their neighbors anomalous
points have much higher score yeah if
the desk
like three that basically means you come
from a region that's three times as
dense now let's talk about the big
recent trend in anomaly detection how do
you checked anomalies in time series so
this is a simple like pump setup given
some activity and nod index by time can
we sort of identify the extreme spikes
or extreme troughs in the time series
and the goal over also identify global
anomalies which are something that's
like an almost on the global sense of
like oh hey this is a super high speak
of overall ever and local anomalies
works like oh hey and like a past day or
two this is like a huge spike or huge
trough what's causing that but it's like
not too big overall so this first
algorithm is called the seasonal hybrid
extreme studentized deviation or
seasonal hybrid ESD this was developed
at Twitter last year so this algorithm
has two steps it has the seasonal
decomposition stage and it has the est
stage and this is why it's called
seasonal hybrid because you combine
seasonality with the EST and again from
this algorithm it's sort of we're gonna
first remove the seasonality trends from
the date time series data and once we
remove the seasonality we now sort have
like the core or the meet of the time
series data and then we're trying to
find anomalies than that so it's like
remove the noise we don't care about
they then find anomalies and stuff we
actually do care about so seasonal
decomposition so essentially you have
some time series and he can sort of
break it down to different components
depending on the method you can use you
can break it down to four components
five components in our case we're gonna
break it down to three components the
trend the seasonality and the residuals
so the trend is sort of like the meat of
the data so if we're looking at user
behavior they're trying to store like
reflects on users behavior over time
over time the seasonality represents
periodic things so periodic things to be
like oh hey it's Friday let's not do any
work in the afternoon because who cares
this Friday has some seasonal trend you
would know it's like every week that
this users activity decreases on Friday
it's not something specific to the user
per se because it could happen to all
employees in the company and then
finally another residual which is this
like a random noise component which is
noise it's just like our error terms for
the time series it can't be explained by
a
your time series cannot be explained by
first to its Polly explained by the
residual noise and the goal is to get
like the meat we want the trend
component and so what we do in this
stage is we remove the season of the
seasonal component from the time series
and then we just focus on the Trank
opponent and so here's an example of
seasonality so I'll say we're looking at
user behavior and it's almost like
there's this overall trend of like
activity is increasing as weeks go by
but you also notice it's like the
seasonality you component like nearly
weekends
negativity dips and so we want to remove
this fact that the activity dips near
the weekends but keep this overall
increasing trend in the data that's the
thing we care about and next we're going
to look at extreme studentized deviate
tests and so this isn't really like
statistical procedure to be like
interval e test for an outlier in data
set and it sort of works like a stano's
standard statistical hypothesis testing
you specify some alpha value and then
you also specify the maximum amount of
numbers you're looking for so you can
say alpha is equal to 0.05 and then
we're also looking for 20 anomalies in
our data set and then the thing about
like your testing and statistics it's
sort of you like I have to compensate
for the fact that you're testing
something multiple times the multiple
testing for set fallacy is like huge
issue statistics if you test the data
set enough times you can eventually find
some like really crazy pattern really
crazy trend there's an xkcd comic unlike
their testing jelly beans for cancer and
they eventually find that green jelly
beans cause cancer because they tested
it like 20-something times and so what
EC does it sort of like naturally
applause this is a statistical
correction to the data to the
methodology so that way you can like
test your hypothesis multiple times you
can use iterative testing without
worrying about the fact that oh hey I'm
testing for 20 outliers it early and I
don't have to worry about the fact I'm
doing 20 different tests each time and
so the way we do this is for each data
point we sort of compute a gee score
which is the absolute value of the z
score and we're easily z-score you can
use the actual z-score of mean mana
divided by standard deviation or he use
that modified z-score I was talking
about earlier
and then you look at the point with the
highest G score so this is a point with
the highest level of extremists in your
data and then using the pre-specified
alpha value K beforehand you calculate
some critical value if your G score is
greater than the critical value you flag
the point as anomalous and then you
remove this point from the data and you
repeat steps to 1 through 5 for the
number of iterations where the number of
iterations is sort of like the maximum
number of run elements you're testing
for so if you're testing 420 anomalies
you repeat this 20 times now until you
find 20 anomalies they could not beat
maybe there's not 20 normalcy new data
set you wouldn't want the thoughts
lately there's 20 anomalies just because
you're looking for 20 that's very bad
don't do that and here's an example of
how this works and so this is from
Twitter's engineering blog so they have
the time series and they find these like
anomalies here of these extreme Peaks
and these extreme spikes up here and so
there's like I said use this algorithm
you can find the anomalies in time
series pretty well this was tested at
alpha equals 0.05
now robust pca so this is algorithm
created in 2009 um so as you might be
familiar with regular pca
i'm assuming is anyone not familiar with
regular pca or does okay didn't see any
hands go up okay
one person so regular pca is you have
some matrix you use singular value
decomposition and map find like a low
rank representation of your data well
this is like one issue was the regular
pca it's pretty sensitive to outliers it
turns out like if you look at the
optimization that law regular pca tries
to solve it's an l2 optimization and so
i was talking about earlier l2
optimizations are sensitive to outliers
and there's also this theorem that we
know it says basically the ability for a
matrix to handle outliers or
specifically corruptions and the data is
sort of proportional to its rank so if
you have a low rank matrix you've
lowered its ability to handle outliers
or corruptions and so we need to be able
to like fix that when we do pca
and so we do we did that is using robust
pca and so the goal of robust pca is
just
identify the normal low rank
representation do we also want to outlaw
identify outliers and finally sort of
identify the noisy points the points
that we don't care about and so this is
used by Netflix in their robust anomaly
detection package they have a blog post
about this as well so if you can you
could look that up afterwards if you're
more interested in the stuff and wade
robust pca works is you basically
specify some value for your threshold
for your singular values you get you use
a threshold and you then you also have a
threshold for your error values and then
you just iterate through the data you
apply the singular value decomposition
and using your threshold you try to
classify points into like normal outlier
and noise they sort of repeat until the
points are classified or repeat to like
convergence in that case like no point
sort of changes this category and so you
just repeat this process you're really
doing this and you can end up with a
anomaly detection method for time series
that allows you to figure out like oh
hey there are these outliers here or
these like super high spikes or the
super high troughs in Netflix so this
could be like their servers okay too
many people are watching strangers
things at this time and now let's talk
about risk scores so this is very useful
in like actual practice this is like a
different from the anomaly the algorithm
stuff let me talking about so when you
do this in practice you sort of want to
treat it more as a regression problem
rather than classification problem you
don't want say anomaly normal you want
to say this is 30 this has a score of 30
or the sense of score 50 where highest
scores mean more anomalous and this is
sort of like a good practice to make a
go from 0 to 100 because people sort of
truly understand it zero hundred scale
ok people see zero okay we know safe we
see 100 and big spooky red letters we
get scared we can I understand that and
this is actually something that like the
US Cyber Security Initiative is actually
pushing for a company that do this kind
of software the bush Wars this risk for
bait so your score base like methodology
because people can understand this more
easily rather than giving them like oh
hey here's some like probably
probability values there's some
likelihood values and so how can we
calculate these risk scores
and so one thing you do I mean it's just
like take your probabilities your test
statistic or your probability or
likelihood account and converted to zero
to a hundred scale it's the probability
value you could just multiply by a
hundred boom you've done both talked
about something a bit more complicated a
bit more interesting so how we use
Bayesian inference to do this stuff so
essentially we have some measure of risk
R so this could be your test statistic
and the local a liar-face this could be
the local outlier factor score and we
want to assume that like R comes from
well some well-defined distribution for
example we're going to assume here let's
say probability getting risk score R is
equal to this exponential distribution
that should be an R not to be okay
and so anyways and so we're gonna use
this exponential distribution because
like all Bayesian statistics we sort of
want something that's easy easily
computable in the end and so with
explanation we'll distribution gives us
like this nice shape that we want where
it's like a lot of low values and
they're like rare extreme value so I'll
show you a graph at the end and what we
can do is like calculate the probability
likelihood so like what's the
probability of getting a risk measure R
given your user data well if you do this
actual like integration L you can get
something like this so you can get the
actual distribution times the
probability of lambda given the data so
this is our prior so we want the
distribution our prior patient
statistics so what can we choose from
our distribution for our prior well if
we're using the exponential distribution
let's use our conjugate prior of the
gamma because the point of the conjugate
prior is basically we want something
that solver rigs the posterior to be
something easy nice and easy at the end
and so you can use Bayes theorem it
tells us that the probability of lambda
give them data is equal to this equation
probability of data given lambda times
the probability of lambda and get over
the probability of data and now
probability Dana given by lambda is just
a likelihood function you basically look
through the data you calculate the light
max likelihood by multiplying the
product of each event occurring and then
you choose your probability of lambda
from the gamma distribution so we get a
computable posterior and so we do this
we get a gamma distribution as our
posterior we get something that's easy
to compute and a way they like calculate
risk scores that's the personalized for
each user
and so this allows us to see useful
because like if you give like you can
have a global risk or function which is
like take all users in and they go
through this one function and then get a
risk score versus personalized where
scores where it's like each users risk
score has their own personalized risk
function and so we can say like okay
maybe this you this is normal for this
user is abnormal for this other user and
so that's what that personalized risk
scores give us and so this is what we
can get from the station inference by
looking at their prior data and their
prior risk scores we can sort of like
come up with a personalized risk or
function if we do this we can get
something like this and so this is
something we really want like this is
the gamma distribution and as a
posterior we sort of get most of our
risk scores are zero there near the left
end like they're not risky and then we
sort of like get this decreasing but we
still get some risky values at the right
end like there's still some suspicious
people we want to be able to fly those
people but for the most part we want to
say that most people are sort of like
normal and safe in your organization if
most people are not normal and safe in
your organization well then again you
have a problem and now finally how we
test these algorithm so be sure to test
your algorithms in various different
environments because anomalies change
from our highest environment specific so
if you're like working in computer
security you want to be able to test in
a small environment so maybe look a
small star table of 10 to 50 compete
employees come on then also tested and a
large company like maybe a hundred
thousand employees you want to see you
like how is your algorithms performance
dipper in this small environment versus
large apartment environment until it
gives you ideas like how the captures
anomalies how well scale so like larger
settings things of that nature and also
because like anomalies are usually rare
you should also try creating it's hard
to say one is anomaly without hindsight
should also create some synthetic
datasets stateís that's where you sort
of like how the anomalies built in and
you know what you're looking for and if
your method cannot like capture the
anomalies in your synthetic data then
you have a problem because if you can't
do it on your fake easy toy example how
you gonna do this in a real world and
finally since you're gonna be like
testing your algorithms continuously
because I said like what is it anonymous
now might not be anomalous in the future
so you need to be like a test you're not
all girls continuously so I recommend
having a sort of like automated testing
or
harness so you can test your algorithms
like every couple of weeks or every
couple days depending on what you're
studying is and this allows you to keep
your algorithms updated as like things
change and as like your problem involves
over time and I guess that's it for my
talk so hello for the look I'll say
you're a factor that you used how do you
choose the best K well how'd you come up
with the best K truth I mean so how do
you pick K / K means I mean that's also
an open problem statisticians the truth
on that so it's like there's no like
best method to pick K I mean there's
different like heuristics you can use
you can test multiple K values on
different scales so like 110 50 100
I specifically use this like one
heuristic of like using log of the
number of data points I'm gonna be
looking at so if I'm looking at data
stuff like 500 users lose the log of
that and use a stop my starting point
and sort of like move up and down and
starting from there and that's like a
good heuristic but like there's no like
best method for picking K cuz like this
is still an open problem statistics
thank you Thanks
hello let's say you were in a scenario
where you were spoiled for choice for
the kind of data that you had or the
kind of characteristics that you could
identify as being pretty risky okay
sorry well I guess how do you how do you
identify pieces of information that may
help you come to a decision to identify
an armless behavior so if it's hard to
identify what an anomaly is but you know
when you see it
how can you see how can you tell what
pieces of data should include in a model
that would model anomalous behavior I
mean so that's like just like how do you
do most data science you need some
domain expertise you need some some
expert to help come in and you also need
to do like some solar selection like for
the case of my problems we sort of have
our own software that we're like things
were monitoring like if you're doing
computer stereo to your start like
modern monitoring the domain controllers
and we have like log files and so we
know we so we can get all the data from
the log files and like we sort of know
like what we're looking for based on
like what the kind of attacks were
looking for so we're looking for like a
brute force attack we know look for the
x y&z and things of that nature but like
it's very specific to the domain and
you're excited we need to do like look
at different features and see what works
best thank you
hi do you have any recommendations or
best practices when you're like training
data set is really small for for anomaly
detection
um not really like any best practices
like I mean there's no like special best
practices for like this specific promise
is like general like what you do when
you have small data sets like you have a
very small view data you have to make do
with you have the best thing you can do
stuff these methods that don't really
require large amounts data so like don't
use deep learning because that requires
use your mouse data just try to prefer
using methods that sort will require
like less amount of data